welcome to this video and it's yacht
blood again and we meet at very high
ratings I'm very high rated and he as
well so that's good I mean it's always a
dangerous opponent and sometimes he's
there was like 2,300 I don't know what
he did down to watch wine or something
okay we can all have our good days and
our bad days so the key is playing this
line in the Queen's onion I'm
experimenting a little bit with allowing
this opening as wide I don't have any
big knowledge now have to admit that how
do you play here you can probably play
this at 93 the most likely continuation
is capture like 93 black will take
Bishop takes Bishop reform this kind of
continuation I have played those
position times myself with black mostly
in in blitz are rapid not in serious
tournament chess tournament chess I'm
did not play the Queen's Indian that
much okay we got a totally different
thing now hmm it's not a move that I've
expected very much if it moves the
bishop
on that one it doesn't look bad right I
mean the combination of a five and c5 is
always a very let's say that's a very
responsible decision to take if you if
you go for that you really weaken
squares but what he what he has he has
got decent development maybe d5 now was
his idea it's very much possible know
that not that's not what he plays mhm
that's him I don't want to take on c6
strategically speaking but if I don't
take them hmm I'm not taking that will
be very slow like night to be five he
plays d higher okay I'm taking that's
not the most ambitious move ever but I
think the other ones weren't better
simply because of development here at
least I'm a little bit quicker on the D
file may be 94 is this leading to
something or the job Bishop f4 Bishop f4
f5 Bishop g5 now that's not leading
anywhere
yeah maybe still it is a very equal ish
position anyway Bishop d7 I was thinking
maybe rook t3 rookie one yeah but it's
as mentioned is this just not it's not
much happening him you can even just
take c3 and plain 94 actually no not
playing this very ambitious Lee but I
didn't see anything right him the only
thing that he probably should avoid is
that I get to get to double his pawns I
think that would be really unnecessary
yeah this is some oh wait wait wait wait
Queenie three okay that's okay it's okay
rookie for a bishop Queenie 525 I can
just play em Bishop f4 there's nothing
happening and move like f 5 i'm not sure
about this is more weakening for black
than anything of course that sets them
the simple way to play okay Queen f4
maybe my king is a little bit quicker
with coming to the center not much
really not much ciao
talk about nothing much going on that's
an uncharacteristically boring game
against this guy but yeah I didn't
really get anything the knight c6 move
was was kind of strong it was leading to
a situation where i really don't don't
have anything I think we're not taking
on c6 I mean this situation if I don't
take on c6 its leading nowhere hmm
interesting
oh wait wait rook g1 years rube d8 I
don't want that hmm so what is it doing
here maybe taking for group g2 okay I
mean that's not not much happening
anyway but there are some little things
that might happen I shouldn't give up
the D file for example that's not a good
idea check okay my king is is active so
that's not bad okay he can give this
check there but where is he going with
that to h5 maybe I don't know ok let's
go here check don't think that leads to
much really
I can do with this pre move if he goes
no f6 is the move okay
I think this is a bit questionable what
you did but I don't think I don't see
what to how to really refute it maybe
there is nothing it still looks kind of
questionable exposing stuff here I
wonder if I can play this looks really
strange but that is h4 h5 not sure it
might be ridiculous not H for what one
was my idea ok yeah a tree is not so
terrible i hope but i wanted to play h
form now ok maybe it's ok yeah
I always hated time when I'm getting
into something that I did not want even
if it's not so bad maybe so I'm going to
check here now my points are we cash c5
can see 5 is the move to come maybe I
did not really need to cover that check
check check kind of awkward check check
DRA offered check what you're playing
for win there with with this sick
seconds or what check Roger Oh game I
really I this is kind of funny if you
try to win on time with 14 seconds
against 12 seconds yeah I know I
probably was Jewish all along I don't
know there was some things happening
here in the same game carolee did not
want to play what I did play he I don't
know this rook age one move was probably
kind of strange but my idea was to go
age form and TI wanted h4 not age three
it's probably I don't know what this is
maybe this is sadly okay for him here
here here nah he always this is probably
ending in a draw somehow the likelihood
is very high that we get to get to some
kind of torture can cam the 111
interesting moment he was this knight c6
move which is really really see I think
equalizing for him I really this is a
tech so I don't have many moves and if I
try to keep it on the board it's it's
probably not leading anywhere yeah and
of course after this is just totally
totally equal maybe maybe I can play for
something about bfm if I'm more precise
because of the slightly better
development and his Queen side is a
little bit weaker than mine but
the compass giving 0.3 with a move like
night a four maybe now maybe where this
is definitely just equal those trades
yeah not a very exciting game but you
cannot get fireworks even against
Yardbird all of the time okay well
thanks for watching